You know, like in C++, we say no raw loops. There's an idea that if you're writing a for loop, if you're writing a while loop, you should scrutinize it. You should figure out if there's a standard algorithm does this, don't write the raw loop, which has a tendency to gather cruft. The difference in a way between Haskell and Lisp, similarly, a mantra in Haskell would be no raw recursions. In Lisp, you write the function and you're dealing with head and tail and you're recursing.
你知道，就像在 C++ 中，我们说不要使用原始循环。有一种观点认为，如果你在写 for 循环，或者在写 while 循环，你应该仔细审视它。你应该弄清楚是否有标准算法可以实现这一点，不要写那种容易堆积冗余代码的原始循环。从某种程度上说，Haskell 和 Lisp 之间的区别在于，Haskell 的一个口头禅是不要使用原始递归。在 Lisp 中，你编写函数时是在处理头部和尾部，并且在进行递归。
Great. In Haskell, if you write a function where you're manually dealing with head and tail, it's kind of like in C++ when we're writing a raw loop. One of the things that languages like Haskell and BQN, one of the sort of next step up they've achieved over languages like C++, Python, whatever, is exactly what you were just saying. We keep making this mistake of when we write algorithms, we don't recognize that we can decouple the traversal of whatever data structure from the actual operation that we're doing on the Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 216, recorded on December 16th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about programming paradigms,
太棒了。在 Haskell 中，如果你编写一个手动处理头部和尾部的函数，这有点像我们在 C++ 中编写原始循环。像 Haskell 和 BQN 这样的语言，它们比 C++、Python 等语言更进一步的地方，正是你刚才所说的。我们总是犯这样的错误：在编写算法时，没有意识到我们可以将数据结构的遍历与我们正在执行的操作解耦。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 216 期，录制于 2024 年 12 月 16 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起，我们聊聊编程范式、
algorithms, and more. So, my first job was programming C. C at that time, at least, and probably still was very procedural. You know, you write functions, you do, you do one thing after another, you keep track of state, right? That is one paradigm. Now, and there are plenty of C++ programs that do that today. Most of them, in fact.
算法等等。所以，我的第一份工作是编写 C 语言。至少在当时，可能现在也是，C 语言非常过程化。你知道，你编写函数，你做完一件事接着做下一件事，你跟踪状态，对吧？这是一种范式。现在，今天仍有大量的 C++ 程序在这样做。事实上，大多数程序都是这样。
You know, object orientation was another paradigm that came along, really had a big heyday in the late 90s through the 2000s. Functional has been taking over this past decade plus um array languages have always been like watching from the sidelines if you like you've really got into them um it seems like there are you know each one of these things teaches you a different way to think right like like yeah um and uh with languages with with with languages like lisp, Lisp family languages, the big way it teaches you to think is recursion, right? You're always thinking about head and tail, you know,
你知道，面向对象是另一种出现的范式，在 90 年代末到 2000 年代确实非常盛行。函数式编程在过去十年左右的时间里一直在接管市场。嗯，数组语言一直像是在场边观望。如果你真的深入了解它们，嗯，似乎每一种语言都能教你一种不同的思考方式，对吧？就像，嗯，对于像 Lisp 家族这样的语言，它教给你最大的思考方式是递归，对吧？你总是思考头部和尾部，你知道，
and you're coding up what to do for the head and then how to recurse on the tail. And I solved a couple of Advent code in Lisp, and it was very nice to do that, right? But then when you learn Haskell, you have the same things available, but, you know, like in C++, we say no raw loops, right? So we've reached, there's an idea that if you're writing a for loop, if you're writing a while loop, you should scrutinize it.
你在编写处理头部的代码，然后思考如何对尾部进行递归。我在 Lisp 中解决过几个 Advent of Code 的题目，这样做非常棒，对吧？但当你学习 Haskell 时，你有同样的东西可用，但是，你知道，就像在 C++ 中，我们说不要使用原始循环，对吧？所以我们已经达成了一种共识，即如果你在写 for 循环，如果你在写 while 循环，你应该审视它。
You should figure out if there's a standard algorithm does this. If there's not a standard algorithm, maybe there's a boost algorithm. Maybe there's some kind of algorithm. It is unlikely that we are every day in our regular jobs inventing algorithms that are new to science. And so there's a recognition that we should call the thing by its right name, form an abstraction, don't write the raw loop, which has a tendency to gather cruft. The difference in a way between Haskell and Lisp, one of the things about their functional styles, they're both sort of functional languages at the core. But I might say that similarly, a mantra in Haskell would be no raw recursions, right? In Lisp, you write the function and you're dealing with head and tail and you're recursing. Great. In Haskell, if you
你应该弄清楚是否有标准算法可以做到这一点。如果没有标准算法，也许有 Boost 算法。也许有某种算法。我们每天在工作中发明的算法不太可能是科学界从未见过的新算法。因此，人们认识到我们应该用正确的名字来称呼它，形成一种抽象，不要写那种容易堆积冗余代码的原始循环。从某种程度上说，Haskell 和 Lisp 之间的区别，关于它们函数式风格的一点是，它们本质上都是函数式语言。但我可能会说，同样地，Haskell 的一个口头禅是不要使用原始递归，对吧？在 Lisp 中，你编写函数时是在处理头部和尾部，并且在进行递归。太棒了。在 Haskell 中，如果你
write a function where you're manually dealing with head and tail, it's kind of like in C++ when we're writing a raw loop, right? There's the idea that really I should be able to express this better using built-in recursion schemes in the language. And I think, you know, array languages maybe have that, but they take it to a different place. They, you know, mask-based programming is about, you know, in the Lisp way of thinking, it's very much minimizing data and data layout and it's bringing to the fore the idea of the evolution of the program right to the point where you can you can model famously in like lecture five of the sick p lectures um Hal Abelson i think shows shows how to model like pairs and therefore lists and all the underlying data like that's not actually you thought that was an array under the hood no that's that's not any kind of data at all that just functions right and in bqn it seems like that
编写一个手动处理头部和尾部的函数，这有点像我们在 C++ 中编写原始循环，对吧？有一种观点认为，我确实应该能够使用语言内置的递归方案更好地表达这一点。我认为，你知道，数组语言可能也有这一点，但它们将其带到了不同的层面。它们，你知道，基于掩码的编程是关于，你知道，在 Lisp 的思维方式中，它非常注重最小化数据和数据布局，它将程序演进的思想推到了前台，甚至到了你可以建模的地步，就像在 SICP 讲座的第五讲中，我想是 Hal Abelson 展示了如何对像对（pairs）这样的东西进行建模，进而对列表和所有底层数据进行建模，就像你以为底层是一个数组，不，那根本不是任何类型的数据，那只是函数，对吧？而在 BQN 中，它似乎
sort of turns around gets put in his head It's like directly composing data, right? You have a data structure, you make another data structure that mirrors it like a mask and use it to select out. So you're just bringing the data to the forefront and using transformations on data. All of which is to say, you know, I think there are lots of different tools here and uh and all of them are very useful in their own way but i don't know if you have ideas about that those observations no no i completely agree with almost everything you said uh i mean i think it was this is goes back to like the very first time we met actually which i believe was at c plus plus now 2019 i was super super early on my we'll call it
那种思维方式被颠倒了过来。它就像直接组合数据，对吧？你有一个数据结构，你制作另一个镜像它的数据结构，比如一个掩码，并用它来选择。所以你只是把数据放在了最前面，并对数据进行转换。所有这些都是为了说，你知道，我认为这里有很多不同的工具，而且它们各自都非常有用，但我不知道你对此有什么看法。不，不，我完全同意你所说的一切。嗯，我的意思是，我认为这可以追溯到我们第一次见面的时候，实际上我相信是在 2019 年的 C++ Now 大会上，当时我在我的，我们称之为
algorithmic ascension journey and you i remember you being super excited just to meet other people who could talk at the level that you're already talking at about who could who could talk exchange these ideas of like this algorithm, this algorithm goes together this way. Well, it's, I mean, it's funny that you, you say that because I think at the time I don't, I didn't even realize really like what, what I was onto. And in fact,
算法提升之旅上还处于非常非常早期的阶段，我记得你当时非常兴奋，只是因为遇到了其他人，他们可以和你已经在谈论的水平上进行交流，可以交流这些想法，比如这个算法，这个算法是这样组合在一起的。嗯，我的意思是，你这么说很有趣，因为我想当时我甚至没有真正意识到我正在做什么。事实上，
when I first gave the meetup version of that talk in the same year in January, my goal was to try and give it at CPPCon. And I had been listening to CPPCast and knew C++ Now was like the expert conference. And I was not interested. Like I did not consider myself an expert. And I remember when I was talking to Bryce, he was like, you got to submit this to C++ Now. And I was like, no, no, no, no way.'m not i'm not going there like i don't have anything to contribute
当我在同一年的一月份第一次在聚会上做那个演讲时，我的目标是尝试在 CPPCon 上做这个演讲。我一直在听 CPPCast，并且知道 C++ Now 是专家会议。我当时并不感兴趣。就像我不认为自己是专家。我记得当我和 Bryce 交谈时，他说，你必须把这个提交给 C++ Now。我说，不，不，不，没门。我不会去那里的，我没有什么可以贡献的。
he convinced me and then when i uh i showed up i was like pretty nervous but like my advantage was that i had almost met like half the people virtually in a way from watching everyone's talks like i had watched your talks i I had watched a bunch of folks talk. So whenever I'd bump into someone, I'd be like, oh, my favorite talk of this was yours, which is a good like ice breaker if, you know, if that's your style. Anyways, and I remember talking to you and just like, I remember one of the things you told me because I was just learning. I was at the phase of like transitioning to c++
他劝服了我，然后当我出现时，我非常紧张，但我的优势在于，通过观看每个人的演讲，我已经在某种程度上虚拟地认识了几乎一半的人。我看过你的演讲，我看过很多人的演讲。所以每当我遇到某人时，我就会说，哦，我最喜欢你的这个演讲，如果这是你的风格的话，这是一个很好的破冰方式。总之，我记得和你交谈，我记得你告诉我的事情之一，因为我当时正在学习。我正处于向 C++ 过渡的阶段。
algorithms are awesome but like man haskell makes it so much easier and i think you were the one that mentioned like oh have you heard of uh like bartaj maluski um and i was like no and and you were like oh yeah like he has been giving talks for years at this conference, basically implementing Haskell stuff at compile time and C++. And that was just like one of like several. You also like led to at least one slide directly in the 2019 edition of that talk where you pointed out that Fibonacci could be uh calculated with adjacent difference which like i think that that was like a a stone that you pushed off a mountain that like rolled into like a whole thesis of mine an algorithmic intuition lighting a fire that was part of that yeah like i remember i remember not believing you um and i think I went and like got my laptop and whipped out Gumball
算法很棒，但 Haskell 让它变得容易多了。我想是你提到了，哦，你听说过 Bartosz Milewski 吗？我说没有，你说，哦，是的，他多年来一直在这个会议上发表演讲，基本上是在编译时用 C++ 实现 Haskell 的东西。那只是几个例子之一。你还直接导致了 2019 年版演讲中至少一张幻灯片的出现，你在其中指出斐波那契数列可以用 adjacent_difference 计算，我想那就像你从山上推下的一块石头，滚成了我的一整篇论文，一种算法直觉，点燃了火花，那是其中的一部分。是的，我记得我不相信你，我想我走过去拿了我的笔记本电脑，打开了 Compiler Explorer，
because I could not believe that that was what adjacent difference did. And I think that led to the insight of like, holy smokes, like anytime you encode the default binary operation or operation in the name, it's so limiting. It's just putting a fence around the way you think about it yeah and like a intellectual box around what something can do and i was like how could you like fibonacci is
因为我无法相信这就是 adjacent_difference 所做的事情。我认为这导致了一个洞察，即天哪，任何时候你在名字中编码默认的二元操作或操作，它都是如此局限。它只是在你思考它的方式周围筑起了一道栅栏。是的，就像在某种东西能做什么的周围画了一个智力盒子，我当时想，你怎么能，斐波那契是
adding how could you possibly use an algorithm that's about subtracting and then you realize oh my goodness it's not about subtracting at all it's about combining adjacent elements together with a binary operation and they've accidentally and i think in is it um uh stepanov's defense i'm not sure if he was the one that named it it was to it was uh adjacent difference in partial sum were specifically named to i think elicit the fact that these were two round tripping functions to be kind of inverses yeah yeah which is a mistake uh even if that's your goal you succeeded in the goal but you've you've made the mistake of obfuscating what you can do with this. Anyways, the point being is that all the stuff that you're talking about, it's like I completely agree with.
加法，你怎么可能使用一个关于减法的算法？然后你意识到，哦，天哪，它根本不是关于减法的，它是关于用二元操作将相邻元素组合在一起。他们意外地，我想是在 Stepanov 的辩护中，我不确定他是否是命名它的人，adjacent_difference 和 partial_sum 被专门命名为，我想是为了引出这两个函数是两个往返函数，是某种逆运算的事实。是的，是的，这是一个错误。即使这是你的目标，你在目标上成功了，但你犯了一个错误，即混淆了你可以用它做什么。总之，重点是，你谈论的所有这些东西，我完全同意。
In Haskell, I rarely ever write recursion. In the same way in C++, I rarely ever write raw loops. And that's not because no one ever said no raw recursion. It's because I don't think of haskell as a recursion language i think of it as every algorithm has already been written it's in it's in a library somewhere data.list data.list.ht data.split i'm not going to go write it because i don't like writing recursion i just like using the dot composition operator or the b1 composition operator in between things that other people wrote anyways you're going to mention something a couple times and uh
在 Haskell 中，我很少写递归。同样在 C++ 中，我很少写原始循环。这并不是因为没有人说过不要使用原始递归。这是因为我不认为 Haskell 是一种递归语言，我认为它是一种每个算法都已经写好，并且在某个库中的语言。data.list，data.list.ht，data.split。我不会去写它，因为我不喜欢写递归，我只是喜欢在别人写的东西之间使用点组合运算符或 BQN 组合运算符。总之，你要提到几次，而且嗯
i was going to agree i was just i was going to say one of the things that other people wrote. Anyways, you were going to mention something a couple of times. I was going to agree. I was just going to say, one of the things that languages like Haskell and BQN, one of the sort of next step up they've achieved over languages like C++, Python, whatever, is exactly what you were just saying. We keep making this mistake of when we write algorithms, we don't recognize that we can decouple the traversal of whatever
我正要同意，我只是想说，别人写的东西之一。总之，你要提到几次。我正要同意。我只是想说，像 Haskell 和 BQN 这样的语言，它们比 C++、Python 等语言更进一步的地方，正是你刚才所说的。我们总是犯这样的错误：在编写算法时，没有意识到我们可以将遍历与我们正在执行的操作解耦。
data structure from the actual operation that we're doing on the loci, right? In C++, it looks like we do that less because we have this large library of algorithms. But in fact, it's a small library of algorithms. Those algorithms pretty much only work to a first approximation they work on linear sequences right as soon as you go into something that's a tree or a graph or something else you are back to rolling your own algorithm and like as not if you are used to programming in c++ and python you are not thinking in the way of let me separate the recursion from the operation or the traversal from the operation, right? Which in languages like
数据结构与我们正在执行的操作，对吧？在 C++ 中，看起来我们这样做的情况较少，因为我们有庞大的算法库。但事实上，那是一个很小的算法库。这些算法基本上只适用于，第一近似值，它们适用于线性序列。一旦你进入树、图或其他东西，你就回到了自己编写算法的状态。而且，如果你习惯于用 C++ 和 Python 编程，你并没有以这种方式思考：让我把递归与操作分开，或者把遍历与操作分开，对吧？而在像
Haskell, BQN, anything like that, sort of the way they lead you to write the code is naturally to do that, I think. Yeah, no, I've heard Adam make this argument. He's one of the panelists on arraycast that that's one of the nice things about apl and bqn in these languages is because they're symbolic you don't actually need to name the symbols which like he's i think take an issue with the fact that in a lot of the documentation we have to try and find ways to name these things so we can speak about them but the naming of them you can fall into that trap again whereas like without the name at first it is conceptually and like intellectually free like uh until you put the name indices on the uh symbol that you know pulls out the corresponding index name without that
Haskell、BQN 这样的语言中，它们引导你编写代码的方式自然就是这样，我认为。是的，不，我听 Adam 提出过这个论点。他是 ArrayCast 的小组成员之一，他说这是 APL 和 BQN 这些语言的好处之一，因为它们是符号化的，你实际上不需要命名这些符号。我想他对于我们在很多文档中必须设法找到命名这些东西的方法以便谈论它们这一事实有异议，但命名它们可能会让你再次陷入那个陷阱，而如果不先命名，它在概念上和智力上是自由的。直到你在符号上加上索引，你知道，它会拉出相应的索引名称，没有那个
there you might be more likely to see that there's a generalization of this where it's really more of a copying thing than it is a a taking the index of thing and and yeah you know speaking of which adjacent difference in in haskell they named correctly uh adjacent map which we then got a version of in c++ 23 with adjacent transform anyways yeah there's uh i don't i don't know what the bqn version of no raw recursion and no raw loops is i'll have to think about that i'll get back to you and think if there's but i think uh maybe there isn't one but maybe there is something that you can identify yeah i think i think yeah and this is getting back to your very original question is you know what is bqn and these languages, if, and that was the thing at the beginning of, I keep on not answering this question because I could just have thoughts
在那里，你可能更有可能看到这有一个泛化，它实际上更像是一个复制的东西，而不是一个取索引的东西。是的，说到这个，adjacent_difference 在 Haskell 中被正确命名为 adjacent_map，我们在 C++ 23 中得到了一个版本，叫 adjacent_transform。总之，是的，我不知道 BQN 版的“不要使用原始递归”和“不要使用原始循环”是什么。我得考虑一下，我会回复你，看看是否有，但我认为，也许没有，但也许有一些你可以识别的东西。是的，我想，是的，这回到了你最初的问题，你知道什么是 BQN 和这些语言，如果，那是开始时的事情，我一直没有回答这个问题，因为我可能只是有想法
that pop into my head is what was it? Problem three that you did with the command line and grep at the beginning of my video and regex, I think I said, you know, really, I want regex for this, but BQN doesn't have a regex library. APL does, but I was doing this in BQN and that's what I would have done if I, if I had that DSL available to me. Yeah. Well, you know, regardless of what languages that you know, I would highly recommend, not you personally, but that one knows, I would highly recommend getting familiar with the command line.
跳进我的脑海，那是什么？你在我的视频开头用命令行和 grep 做的第三个问题，还有正则表达式，我想我说，你知道，真的，我想要正则表达式来做这个，但 BQN 没有正则表达式库。APL 有，但我是在 BQN 中做这个的，如果我有那个 DSL 可用，我就会那样做。是的。好吧，你知道，无论你懂什么语言，我强烈建议，不是你个人，而是人们，我强烈建议熟悉命令行。
You know. Oh, yeah, yeah. Just string together, like, grep, tr x args find yeah and when you need them said an orc tons and tons of problems become become trivial you know i i've i've had situations where uh where i've been on a team and and um you know the day after this happened someone another program on the team came to me and, you know, we were chatting about what we did yesterday. And he said, oh, I wrote this Python script to find all these files and zip them up, right, for localization or whatever. And I spent half a day on it.
你知道。哦，是的，是的。只需把 grep、tr、xargs、find 串在一起，是的，当你需要它们时，sed 和 awk，成吨成吨的问题就变得微不足道了。你知道，我遇到过这样的情况，我在一个团队中，嗯，你知道，这件事发生的第二天，团队里的另一个程序员来找我，我们聊了聊昨天做了什么。他说，哦，我写了这个 Python 脚本来查找所有这些文件并将它们压缩，对吧，为了本地化或其他什么。我花了半天时间。
And I'm confused at this point confused this one like why why would you spend half a day writing python to do that when it's literally like 10 seconds on the command line yeah but they didn't make him feel bad over it i just you know you're one of today's lucky 10 000 yeah sort of thing yeah and it makes me uh think of like the times when i've learned a new like you've got your toolbox of command line tools yours is definitely larger than mine i did some said slash i don't actually think i've ever done any awk um but i've done some said stuff in the past but like definitely do learn a bit of awk do learn a bit of orc it's a fantastic swiss army knife it's come up before multiple times when when we've been chatting um but like one of the things that i
我当时很困惑，为什么你会花半天时间写 Python 来做这件事，而它在命令行上字面上只需要 10 秒钟。是的，但他们没有让他为此感到难过，我只是，你知道，你是今天那 10,000 个幸运儿之一，那种感觉。是的，这让我想起我学习新工具的时候，比如你拥有你的命令行工具箱，你的肯定比我的大。我做过一些 sed，我实际上认为我从来没有做过任何 awk，但我过去做过一些 sed 的东西，但一定要学一点 awk，一定要学一点 awk，它是一把出色的瑞士军刀。在我们聊天时，它已经多次出现过了。但就像我
learned was the the back ticks for evaluation like that that is probably like a a small insight in the way that my brain works because when i learned that small trick because you there's two ways to spell that dollar parens yeah exactly dollar parens and i think because there's two ways to spell that. The dollar parens. Exactly. Dollar parens. And I think even there's like an eval thing, but like the back text was like a couple characters less. And it then, I was just, it made me so happy because it's a more elegant way. It's like, it's back to the whole partial application.
学到的一件事是用于求值的反引号，这可能是我大脑工作方式中的一个小洞察，因为当我学到那个小技巧时，因为有两种拼写方式，美元符号加圆括号，是的，完全正确，美元符号加圆括号。我想因为有两种拼写方式。美元符号加圆括号。完全正确。美元符号加圆括号。我想甚至还有一个 eval 的东西，但反引号少几个字符。然后，我只是，它让我非常高兴，因为它是一种更优雅的方式。它回到了整个部分应用。
Like when there's a simpler, more elegant way to do things and you're able to leverage like a whole tool belt of these things, it makes it painful to go back to the way you had to do it before. And it's very much like programming. Like when you're on the command line, you're not like it's like programming in a REPL, right? You're not writing out this 100, 200 characters cold. You're building it up piecemeal. You're playing with it.
就像当有一种更简单、更优雅的方法来做事情，并且你能够利用这些东西的整个工具带时，再回到以前必须做的方式就会很痛苦。这非常像编程。就像当你在命令行上时，你不是，这就像在 REPL 中编程，对吧？你不是在写这 100、200 个字符的代码。你是零敲碎打地构建它。你在玩它。
You know, it's real easy to do yeah it's uh and so yeah to circle back for the 10th time to your you know what is it great for it's best for things where reduction scans these kinds of things you need to reach for but my follow-up to that is that's like 98% of like if I plan to do... Of your day job? Well, just of all of my programming. Like even when you're going to read from some JSON file or do some kind of, you know, I do some geospatial stuff every once in a while. The code that I end up writing in Python or whatever, it's just like the kind of code that I would be writing in BQN. But it's just more painful and I'm reaching to a third-party library here oh a built-in function or whatever and it's
你知道，这真的很容易做到。是的，它是，所以，为了第 10 次回到你的“它最适合什么”，它最适合那些你需要求助于归约、扫描这些东西的地方。但我的后续问题是，这就像我 98% 的……你的日常工作？好吧，只是我所有的编程。即使当你打算从某个 JSON 文件读取或做某种，你知道，我偶尔会做一些地理空间的东西。我最终用 Python 或其他语言写的代码，它就像我会在 BQN 中写的代码。但它只是更痛苦，我在这里求助于第三方库，或者内置函数或其他什么，它
like bqn as i learn more about it and these array languages in general it's like it does the common stuff so much better than every other language i know like reduction scans etc and then it has the ability to do you know all the other stuff maybe not as elegantly but like it does the common path so much better and that's the thing is people think of it as like oh you need arbitrarily ranked arrays and blah blah blah no you don't think what what if i just restrict like you we said earlier that uh algorithms basically they just work on 1d sequences it's like that's a subset of what APL does. I think of like, yeah,
就像 BQN，随着我更多地了解它，以及这些数组语言，它做常见事情的方式比我所知的任何其他语言都要好得多，比如归约、扫描等，然后它有能力做，你知道，所有其他事情，也许不像那样优雅，但它在常见路径上做得好得多。这就是人们认为它像，哦，你需要任意秩的数组等等，不，你不需要。想一想，如果我只是限制，就像我们之前说的，算法基本上只适用于一维序列，这只是 APL 所做的一个子集。我想，是的，
APL is just like a superset of the programming I was doing in C plus plus algorithm land. And then it turns out, not only do you get one D sequences, you get all the dimensions. And then on top of that, you're discovering like four or five different paradigms. This mask programming under programming is just,
APL 只是我在 C++ 算法领域所做编程的一个超集。然后事实证明，你不仅得到了 1D 序列，你还得到了所有的维度。然后在此之上，你正在发现四五种不同的范式。这种掩码编程、下编程（under-programming）简直是，
it's mind blowing. Like this, like perform an-programming is just, it's mind-blowing, like this, like perform an operation and then do something and do the reverse of it. Oh, I see what you mean. Under, yeah, yeah, yeah. I get, you know, I was wondering what you meant by that. It's such a useful tool. So let's make that a little clearer for the listener.
令人大开眼界。就像这个，执行一个操作，然后做某事，然后做它的逆运算。哦，我明白你的意思了。Under，是的，是的，是的。我明白，你知道，我一直在想你说的那个是什么意思。这是一个非常有用的工具。所以让我们为听众把这一点说得更清楚一点。
Oh, okay, yeah. When you say under-programming, you are talking about transforming your data into some form where you run an algorithm and then transforming back. So, the algorithm is performed under some reversible transformation. Yeah. That's one way we can say it. And this ties into a quote that I heard once that – what is that?
哦，好的，是的。当你谈论“下编程”（under-programming）时，你是在谈论将你的数据转换成某种形式，在那里你运行一个算法，然后转换回来。所以，算法是在某种可逆转换下执行的。是的。这是我们可以说的一种方式。这与我曾经听到的一句名言有关，那是什么？
The book of – the Gang of Four book that's patterns? Pattern matching. No, sorry That's patterns. Pattern matching. No, sorry. Design patterns, not pattern matching. Design patterns. And I can't remember who said the quote, but it was something to the effect of design patterns are just like missing. Do you know what I'm talking about? Yes.
那本书——四人帮那本关于模式的书？模式匹配。不，抱歉，那是模式。模式匹配。不，抱歉。设计模式，不是模式匹配。设计模式。我不记得是谁说的这句名言，但大意是设计模式就像缺失的东西。你知道我在说什么吗？是的。
I think it was Peter Norvig. Okay. Does that sound right to you? Yeah. okay does that sound right to you yeah and but it's this idea that design patterns are merely there to address flaws or like missing things in a certain language lacking things which like you go from language to language sometimes you have some language facility or library thing and now you no longer have a need for like for instance the visitor pattern like we need that until we have something like pattern matching you know then you no longer need the visitor pattern like we need that until we have something like pattern matching you know then you no longer need the visitor pattern is that correct well okay the visitor patterns i'm
我想是 Peter Norvig。好的。这听起来对吗？是的。好的，这听起来对吗？是的，但这是一种观点，即设计模式仅仅是为了解决某种语言中的缺陷或缺失的东西，缺乏某些东西，就像你从一种语言转到另一种语言，有时你有一些语言设施或库的东西，现在你不再需要像，例如访问者模式，我们需要它，直到我们有了像模式匹配这样的东西，你知道，然后你就不再需要访问者模式了，你知道，然后你就不再需要访问者模式了，这是正确的吗？好吧，好的，访问者模式我
going to take issue with that the visitor patterns are probably a poor a bad example of what i'm reaching for example because the visitor pattern is not really about visiting things the visitor pattern is a solution to the expression problem right right it's turning you know in an object in your in your standard object oriented languages it's and i'm including c++ even though i wouldn't really say c++ is not sure but it's that in that model of object orientation it's easy to create new types it's easy to subclass things it's easy to you know derive and uh and extend um but it's hard to create new things. It's easy to, you know, derive and extend. But it's hard to create new functionality.
要对此提出异议，访问者模式可能是一个糟糕的例子，因为我所追求的例子，因为访问者模式并不是真正关于访问东西，访问者模式是表达式问题（expression problem）的一个解决方案，对吧？对吧？它正在转变，你知道，在一个对象中，在你的标准面向对象语言中，它是，而且我包括 C++，即使我不会真正说 C++ 不是，不确定，但在那种面向对象模型中，创建新类型很容易，子类化东西很容易，派生和扩展很容易，但创建新东西很难。创建新功能很难。
If you have a class hierarchy and you want to add a function, add a member function, you need to thread it through every part of that class hierarchy, right? And in functional languages, to a certain extent, it's the other way around. It's very easy to add new functionality, but because they have pattern matching, right? If you have pattern matching, you have functions.
如果你有一个类层次结构，并且你想添加一个函数，添加一个成员函数，你需要把它穿插到那个类层次结构的每个部分，对吧？而在函数式语言中，在某种程度上，情况正好相反。添加新功能非常容易，但因为它们有模式匹配，对吧？如果你有模式匹配，你就有函数。
Every function you write matches the patterns of your classes. And so you've turned the problem on its head. It's hard to, it's easy to add functions, but it's hard to add new types because you would need to go and change all of the pattern matching places to get a new type. So that's a fundamental dichotomy, and it's known as the expression problem. And the visitor pattern changes the one form into the other form.
你编写的每个函数都匹配你的类的模式。所以你把问题颠倒过来了。添加函数很容易，但添加新类型很难，因为你需要去改变所有模式匹配的地方来获得一个新类型。所以这是一个基本的二分法，它被称为表达式问题。而访问者模式将一种形式转变为另一种形式。
So for languages that have object orientation, and it's easy to add classes, types, what the visitor pattern does, it makes it easy to add functions. And I think Gasper Asman has a really good talk about the expression problem. I'll find a link and throw it in the show notes. I think that was him. I'll fix it in post if it wasn't, but I'm pretty sure it was. So anyway, I agree with you, but I just think the visitor pattern is a bad example. It's a can of worms when we open the visit pattern well the so the the reason i brought it up though was because uh under obfuscates or makes um a couple things in both c++ and haskell
所以对于有面向对象的语言，添加类、类型很容易，访问者模式所做的是，它使添加函数变得容易。我认为 Gasper Asman 有一个关于表达式问题的非常好的演讲。我会找到一个链接并把它放在节目笔记中。我想那是他。如果不是他，我会在后期修正，但我很确定是他。所以总之，我同意你的观点，但我只是认为访问者模式是一个糟糕的例子。当我们打开访问者模式时，它是一个麻烦的根源。好吧，我提出它的原因是因为“下”（under）混淆了，或者使……在 C++ 和 Haskell 中
as those are the languages we've been mentioning unnecessary or not unnecessary but there's a different way for solving it so one of my kind kind of irritations is that in Haskell, you have two different types of scans. You've got scan L and scan R. One's for the left, one's for the right. But in BQN, you only need one because a right scan is just a left scan under reverse which modulo performance concerns because obviously if you're going to be actually doing a copy uh and i'm actually not sure how under reverse i know a lot of them have like idiom recognition so you're not actually completely doing copies you're just once again doing some kind of view like thing but it's a very nice way to conceptualize, like I can do things.
因为它们是我们提到的语言，不必要的，或者不是不必要的，但有另一种解决它的方法。所以我的一个烦恼是，在 Haskell 中，你有两种不同类型的扫描。你有 scanL 和 scanR。一个是左边的，一个是右边的。但在 BQN 中，你只需要一个，因为右扫描只是左扫描在反转下的结果，这取决于性能考虑，因为显然如果你真的要进行复制，而且我实际上不确定“下反转”是如何工作的，我知道它们中的很多有类似惯用语识别的东西，所以你实际上并没有完全进行复制，你只是再次进行某种视图之类的东西，但这是一种非常好的概念化方式，就像我可以做事情。
And it's like, and some people might be thinking, well, now I like our scam better. What about all the other operations though, that don't have the right equivalence that you'd need to go and roll yourself? It's like,
而且就像，有些人可能会想，好吧，现在我更喜欢我们的扫描。但是所有其他没有右等价物，你需要自己去编写的操作呢？就像，
well now we have a generic higher order thing that I can just apply this operation under this. And it's, what about under transpose? What about under some sort what actually i don't know if sort works because it has to be something that is reversible in a sense or invertible yeah yeah i think it again i'm going to kind of say that haskell l and r scan was maybe not the best example because uh it's not just performance concerns of putting a reverse in, it's laziness
好吧，现在我们有一个通用的高阶东西，我可以把这个操作应用在它之下。而且，关于“下转置”呢？关于“下某种排序”呢？实际上我不知道排序是否有效，因为它必须是某种在某种意义上是可逆的或可逆的东西。是的，是的，我想我再次会说 Haskell 的 L 和 R 扫描可能不是最好的例子，因为这不仅仅是放入反转的性能考虑，还有惰性
as well, right? And so there are real reasons, thinking about laziness, like the canonical example is like, Haskell has what do they call reduce in Haskell?
也是，对吧？所以有真正的原因，考虑惰性，就像典型的例子是，Haskell 把 Haskell 中的 reduce 叫什么？
Fold? Yeah. So Haskell has fold L and fold l prime yeah the prime meaning it evaluates strictly not lazily and and and fold r right which is right to left um and the rule of thumb is basically never use fold l to a first approximation right because if you're doing a left fold, you probably want strictness or you probably, it is performance-wise much better to be strict in the first argument. Conversely, if you're doing a right fold, the performance of right fold comes from the laziness. Yeah. These are things that I skate over a lot of the time because in haskell well in haskell i've never checked in any production haskell code in my life so
Fold？是的。所以 Haskell 有 foldL 和 foldl'，是的，那个撇号意味着它严格求值，而不是惰性求值，还有 foldR，它是从右到左的，经验法则是基本上永远不要使用 foldL，作为第一近似值，对吧？因为如果你在做左折叠，你可能想要严格性，或者你可能，在性能上，在第一个参数中严格要好得多。相反，如果你在做右折叠，右折叠的性能来自于惰性。是的。这些是我大部分时间忽略的事情，因为在 Haskell 中，好吧，在 Haskell 中，我这辈子从来没有提交过任何生产级的 Haskell 代码，所以
i play fast and loosed with fast and loose with my folds yeah i mean and that's fine but now i'm gonna hit you with the killer question like so so there's been a killer question in the wings this whole time just one more question. So I've known professional programmers who programmed in functional languages. And to a large extent, you know, they don't spend their days carefully crafting algorithms. They spend their days wondering about how to interface library A with library B and wrangling the build process. So, you know, using BQN in a professional sense, which I'm pretty sure you don't currently do, but maybe you know people who do.
我对待我的折叠非常随意。是的，我的意思是，这很好，但现在我要用一个杀手级问题来问你，所以，一直以来都有一个杀手级问题在等待。再问一个问题。所以我认识一些在函数式语言中编程的专业程序员。在很大程度上，你知道，他们并没有花时间仔细地编写算法。他们花时间思考如何将库 A 与库 B 接口，以及处理构建过程。所以，你知道，在专业意义上使用 BQN，我非常确定你目前没有这样做，但也许你认识这样做的人。
You've certainly talked to people on Arraycast who do probably. What happens there? One of the great things about programming in, let's say, a mainstream language like Python or c++ is there are there are off-the-shelf solutions for just doing the same thing in ci as you do at your command line right what does ci look like in in bqn or one of these array languages ci i think across the board ci is non-existent i know that like so there's bqn which is a language in its infancy in that probably my biggest complaint right now is that there's no any form of like a package manager and even even the idea of libraries and packages in the array community is controversial
你肯定和 ArrayCast 上这样做的人聊过。那里发生了什么？在像 Python 或 C++ 这样主流语言中编程的伟大之处之一是，有现成的解决方案可以在 CI 中做和你命令行中一样的事情，对吧？BQN 或这些数组语言之一中的 CI 是什么样的？CI，我认为在整个范围内，CI 是不存在的。我知道，比如有 BQN，这是一种处于起步阶段的语言，可能我目前最大的抱怨是没有任何形式的包管理器，甚至在数组社区中，库和包的概念也是有争议的，
because some folks don't believe in dependencies which the more and more I use these languages, the more and more I disagree with that. Because at a certain point, you do not want to be writing the world, which is what some people advocate for. Right. A similar thing happens in Lisp, right? The more things change, the more they stay the same, right? same right um if we look at lisp the the ease of writing things in lisp to a certain extent for a long time meant that yeah the package ecosystem was very poor yeah because lisp is a language where you want to write something well you you build the language up to to make a dsl in which you can easily express your problem that is the lisp way if i could say that yeah professional lisp writer.
因为有些人不相信依赖项，我使用这些语言越多，我就越不同意这一点。因为在某一点上，你不想编写整个世界，这就是有些人所提倡的。对。Lisp 中也发生了类似的事情，对吧？事情变化得越多，它们就越保持不变，对吧？同样，嗯，如果我们看 Lisp，在 Lisp 中编写东西的容易程度在很长一段时间内意味着，是的，包生态系统非常糟糕。是的，因为 Lisp 是一种语言，你想写点什么，好吧，你构建语言来制作一个 DSL，在其中你可以轻松地表达你的问题，这就是 Lisp 的方式，如果我可以这样说的话，是的，专业的 Lisp 编写者。
But then I don't think it's that way anymore. You have folks like Zach Bean who wrote Quick Lisp, I think, and Package Managers. I forget what it's called. It's got ASDF, is it called? But yeah, Lisp has a package ecosystem these days, thanks to efforts of people like that. And anyway, so where do you think this is going with array languages?
但我认为现在不是那样了。你有像 Zach Beane 这样的人，他写了 Quicklisp，我想，还有包管理器。我忘了它叫什么了。它有 ASDF，是叫这个吗？但是的，多亏了像那样的人的努力，Lisp 这些天有了一个包生态系统。总之，你认为数组语言的发展方向是什么？
I can't predict, but I can hope. And what I hope for is that a language like BQN comes up with a package management and kind of like ecosystem solution for this stuff. And on top of that, a part of writing array code is that everyone has a different style, not dissimilar from Lisp and, you know, Racket, where you can very quickly, there's a proliferation of DSLs. And I want, I don't necessarily need to be the dictator that decides the style, but like something closer to Rust and Rust format.
我无法预测，但我可以希望。我所希望的是，像 BQN 这样的语言能提出一种包管理，以及某种生态系统解决方案。而且最重要的是，编写数组代码的一部分是每个人都有不同的风格，这与 Lisp 和 Racket 没有什么不同，在那里你可以非常快地，有 DSL 的激增。我想要，我不一定需要成为决定风格的独裁者，但像更接近 Rust 和 Rustfmt 的东西。
And like, even as something I think that's configurable where we do get some, you know, we don't want all BQN code looking different, but like, so something towards package management, standardized linting, formatting tools and testing frameworks.
而且，即使我认为这是可配置的，我们确实得到了一些，你知道，我们不希望所有的 BQN 代码看起来都不同，但像，所以朝着包管理、标准化 linting、格式化工具和测试框架的方向发展。
And then from there you get to ci um this is for bqn we'll see what happens there i know that at uh dialogue the company that makes uh the apl interpreter they're also working on a bunch of tooling so i know they have like a package manager called i'm gonna mess this up i think it's tartan or tatan, something like that. And they're all Apple based things. So I think one of those is like a tart. And I know that there's like a testing framework. So they're starting to build this stuff. But you have to remember or know if you if you didn't know the listener didn't know from before.
然后从那里你到达 CI，这是针对 BQN 的，我们将看看那里会发生什么。我知道在 Dyalog，制造 APL 解释器的公司，他们也在致力于一系列工具。所以我知道他们有一个叫，我要把它搞砸了，我想是 Tartan 或 Tatan，类似那样的包管理器。它们都是基于 APL 的东西。所以我认为其中一个是 Tartan。我知道有一个测试框架。所以他们开始构建这些东西。但你必须记住或知道，如果你，如果你不知道，听众之前不知道，
APL is is shares a similarity with small talk in that it's a workspace based language which is completely different than how a lot of ci systems you're not starting from this like workspace environment you're typically starting from code that's either compiled and then executed or already you've got some binary or executable thing so to do something where you're loading a workspace and loading like the act of running something from a script and dialogue involves with this kind you have to use something called dialogue link which i think in the background is running this workspace kind of box right it's like loading a default workspace image exactly exactly i think code into it i could be wrong uh because it would it would seem like why not just write an interpreter that executes it and it's like well they've got i think hundreds of thousands of lines of this interpreter code that works this way it's not it's not a small
APL 与 Smalltalk 有相似之处，因为它是一种基于工作区（workspace）的语言，这与许多 CI 系统完全不同，你不是从这种工作区环境开始的，你通常是从已经编译然后执行的代码开始的，或者你已经有了一些二进制或可执行的东西。所以要做一些加载工作区和加载类似从脚本运行东西的行为，Dyalog 涉及这种，你必须使用一种叫 Dyalog Link 的东西，我想它在后台运行这种工作区盒子，对吧？它就像加载一个默认的工作区镜像，完全正确，完全正确，我想代码进入它，我可能是错的，因为这看起来像为什么不只是写一个执行它的解释器，就像，好吧，他们有我想几十万行的这种以这种方式工作的解释器代码，这不是一个小
thing to um have it be like a scripting language like python um and so uh it's a sad answer to your question is that yeah a lot of this stuff doesn't exist at all and my hope is that like if we get a language whether that's bqn or wewa or some version of apl that comes with this stuff i think the interest in the language would skyrocket because right now i love bqn so much that like i'm willing to go and write like the uh simple versions of this tooling for myself because like it's like you know there's some quote i heard someone saying is that like you know a language has to inspire people to a certain extent that they're willing to suffer um in its infancy and like okay i am i am that person right now like i
事情，让它像 Python 那样成为一种脚本语言，所以，对你的问题的悲伤回答是，是的，很多这些东西根本不存在。我的希望是，如果我们得到一种语言，无论是 BQN 还是 Wewa，或者某种带有这些东西的 APL 版本，我认为人们对这种语言的兴趣会飙升，因为现在，我非常喜欢 BQN，以至于我愿意去为自己编写这些工具的简单版本，因为就像，你知道，我听到有人说的一句名言是，你知道，一种语言必须在某种程度上激励人们，以至于他们愿意在它的起步阶段受苦，而好吧，我现在就是那个人，我
am willing to not only suffer but like write this stuff myself just because it it enables me to write more of this code on my free time. Like if I can make BQN the entirety of my command line scripting. So I, instead of going to grep and whatnot, I just, I hop down into a BQN like session. I can do that there. You know, it's got a super easy way to load files and whatnot in the command line. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP, the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
愿意不仅受苦，而且自己编写这些东西，仅仅因为它使我能够在空闲时间编写更多的这种代码。如果我能让 BQN 成为我命令行脚本的全部。所以，我不用去 grep 之类的，我只是，我跳进一个 BQN 会话。我可以在那里做。你知道，它有一种在命令行中加载文件之类的超级简单的方法。一定要查看这些节目笔记，在你的播客应用程序中或在 ADSP, the podcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
I am the anti brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是反括号派。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。